dans ce genre de gala il y a toujours un
moment sur scène où le public étonné
voit arriver le directeur qui va décorer
un de ses bons serviteurs
les choses parce qu'il arrive je la mets
que l'avait pourtant bien dit vous ne
riez pas du tout c'est toujours toujours
dernier moment on n'a pas des paroles et
obligés quand même
au fil des pages
je n'arrive pas ce cas les amis je ne
suis pas responsable le directeur
il ne vient pas il n'y a pas grand monde
annoncé pourtant là nos placements
démarré très bien et oui je comprends la
semaine dernière il avait déjà 12
fauteuils évidemment très bon direct ou
ce fauteuil sur 2500 blessés par
guillaume gamelin facettes est un départ
est important que ces amendes et alger
parce que j'ai passé d'un coup d'un seul
coup ça s'est arrêté
oui on remarquer dans ce genre de gars
là c'est pas tellement la location qui
compte c'est le bureau oui c'est vrai
mais enfin on n'a pas fait que des
heureux non plus non mais ça c'est la
grêle ya pas eu de grève non mais la
météo en avait annoncé annoncé de la
grêle balle en l'air les gens n'ont pas
voulu c'est ce qu'e oui il faut bien
dire que de toute manière cette période
de l'année c'est pas une bonne période
et c'est bien là la seconde quinzaine de
février qu'on le veuille ou non a
toujours été méfiant savent rien des
oiseaux ça mais j'en parlais avec le
directeur général du quotidien on aurait
dû dire ce qu'elle a beaucoup plus tôt
dans le mois
osons penser vous non parce que début
février ses progrès non plus et tout le
monde est aux sports d'hiver
oui m'enfin pas tout le monde au moins
cent mille personnes
terminées les autres avec les autres il
fait le tiers provisionnel oui alors
évidemment il aurait fallu faire ça leur
paraît molle fin janvier pensez-vous
rentrer le terme et le tiers sont
mauvaises et la première quinzaine entre
les facteurs qui font pas bon non plus
non écoutez je vais vous dire masque qui
ont été astucieux je discute jamais
faire ça juste avant noël
juste avant noël riz c'est pas bon c'est
ça mon sorte pas avant noël
oui alors carrément à noël aba'a noël
c'est pas bon non plus octroyer manche
dimanche
et oui et après noël après noël ils sont
au lit malades d'ailleurs beaucoup les
fêtes c'est pareil il la même chose qui
pourrait bien quitter fait que les
environs de près c'est pareil le mardi
gras avec du mardi gras et prépare la
pop
oui le jour ils mangent les crêpes le
lendemain ils ont une indigestion
clarisse et un merci mais je pensais
quand même que l'automne était dans
l'ensemble était meilleure
les spectacles ensuite ça dépend où
savez ça si vous êtes dépendant ça ne
dépendra pas chaud ça dépend ça dépend
de la récolte du blé ça dépend des films
ça dépend de l'humeur des gens rient il
fait pas assez froid pour s'enfermer
dans un t1 puis là l'autre côté il fait
plus assez chaud pour sortir de chez soi
à l'origine les gens viennent pas oui
mais non novembre c'est un bon vent peut
ne pas être mauvais mais cette année
cette année il a été deux fois il a été
déjà ce point compté sélection
comprenait deux tours d'élections
législatives
sa pompe du monde déjà sa femme mais
enfin n'exagérons rien ça me fait quand
même que deux jours sur trois abonnés
faut pas calculer comme ça n'en faut pas
calculer comme ça parce que les gens ils
pensent huit jours avant oui on savoir
comment ils vont voter oui et puis les
jours un peu pour savoir s'ils ont eu
raison de voter comme ça ça fait déjà
quinze jours
s'il ya ballottage ou multiplié par deux
vous avez votre moi qui s'écroula oui je
parle pas d'octobre bien entendu parce
qu'octobre c'est la rentrée des classes
seul terme
vous avez l'ouverture de la chasse alors
restez vous avez la fermeture de la
pêche mais voilà vous rendez compte
willocq d'ailleurs c'est toujours le
désert dont les singles c'est bien connu
et bah après octobre
oui après octobre mon vieux vous abordez
les mois d'été à septembre était de 5
ans et croyez moi oui septembre si avant
guerre avant de dire septembre était un
bon mois pour le théâtre et puis il fait
trop beau maintenant alors c'est plus
c'est vrai y'a plus de saison
c'est ça c'est ça qui nous tue alors
vous avez bon alors vous voyez vous avez
septembre oui juillet juin vous avez
quatre mois qu'ils sont biffés on n'en
parle pas j'aurai encore même si vous
croyez moi je crois pas mais on joue un
peu avec les bals de rues les bals de
rues et dames
le 14 juin le 14 juin la fête nationale
ah bah c'est vrai mais je pensais plus
elle s'est toutefois il pensé oh non ça
se voit c'est pas bon après moi mais
vous avez le mois de mai bas on retombe
dans le bois des anniversaires
l'anniversaire du travail de l'agent
sion de l'armistice dans ma belle soeur
oui alors eh ben oui elle régresse
depuis pas il reste quoi avril alors
qu'ils restent avril mais avril c'est
pas bon non plus pourquoi
ah oui c'est pas bon en plus je veux
dire parce qu'ils sont les premiers
beaux jours vous savez ça maintenant
alors dès qu'on aborde marcillac
mauricienne et c'était parce que les
gens partent en week-end rick parry pour
le week end du vendredi au lundi sont à
la campagne à se faire d'illusions dont
vous avez déjà automatiquement quatre
jours qui tombe ya le jeudi je compte
pas le jeudi c'est le jour des enfants
je conduis jeudi il reste quoi
le mardi et le mercredi oui m'enfin de
marville mercredi les gens sortent quand
même avis y'a regarde la télévision
parfois ceux qui n'ont pas la télévision
ils vont chez ceux qui l'on sent la
télévision fait nommer mentor au mois
d'avril
oui alors il reste quoi y aura six mois
de mars
freeney sortent pas en mars pourquoi à
cause des événements quels événements
baisse coach et moi pourquoi est ce
qu'il y aurait pas d'événements au mois
de mars
il ya toujours des événements au mois de
mars si jamais j'ai jamais vu un mois de
mars en événements oui c'est vrai mais
alors écouter alors je ne vois pas
l'heure il faut retomber alors tombé en
février bien février bien février
reading 18 août alors que ça n'était pas
une bonne date les trois premières
semaines effectivement ne sont pas
bonnes
oui la 4e dan williams était pas tendres
je parle pas bien sûr les 26 27 et 28
qui sont tout à fait sûr mars alors ça
c'est mauvais ça c'est pas bon mais oui
mais leur indique mme alors à votre avis
quelle est la date idéale c'est ça le 24
24 février
mais pourquoi parce que c'est la veille
du 25 et alors les gens sont contents
ils sortent à bah oui c'est vrai ça mais
bon c'est pas de chance à un jour près
ont refusé du monde
lac très bien alors je vais vous lire un
passage du lac le lac ainsi toujours
poussé vers de nouveaux rivages dans la
nuit éternelle emporté sans retour ne
pourrons nous jamais sur l'océan dh
je t'ai langres un sale jour au lac
l'année à peine infinie sa carrière les
prêts des flots chéri qu'elle devait
revoir regard je viens seul m'asseoir
sur cette pierre ou tu la vis à soir
qemu si c'est ainsi sous ses rages
profondes ainsi tu ta brisait sur ses
flancs décharné ainsi le vent jeter et
légumes de saison d' sur papier adoré un
soir dans souvient-il nous voyons en
silence on entendait trop loin sur
l'ondé sous les cieux cas le bruit des
rameurs qui frappait en cadence des
flots harmonieux alors là j'en ai passé
c'est là il lui parle avec la bonne
femme alors l'aimé bien il parle il
résume le côté humain de la poésie qui
comprennent que ça ferait trop long et
mondon reymondon parce que ça c'est vrai
et mon temps et mon don de leurs
fugitive rateront nous jouissons l'homme
n'a point de porc le train n'a point de
rive
il coule et nous passons
quand
entrée 2 e leurs amis entraidons c'est
un vrai plaisir pour nous de vous
accueillir ici heureux de vous présenter
aux téléspectateurs monsieur rondins
directeur adjoint à la direction voit
que non ça n'est pas exactement ça non
en fait je suis directeur adjoint à la
sous direction des comités directeurs de
la direction générale abri mais je crois
que oui en fait je sais ce que vous
allez me dire je fais fonctions de
sous-directeur mais ma direction n'est
pas attachée à la même direction
si fait que je ne dépend pas directement
la direction on le suivait je vous suis
je vous suis je vous suis très
reconnaissant de bien vouloir vous après
c'est la moindre des choses pensée est
très rare je vous présente monsieur
gathemo puisque trop chefs de services
d'accor pour vous faire un facteur avec
la porteuse de pain naturellement mais
alors essayez de vous faire
subventionner par les boulangers mais
naturellement pas pourquoi pas oui elles
auront passera avant le journal télévisé
bas nous avons déjà la pause café nous
avons la pause content c'est pas plus
mal
certainement voilà très bientôt on va
servir voilà vous et moi j'avais une
petite affaire à régler un signe évident
si vous nous offrir quelque chose à voir
y a du jus de pomme ah bah oui nous
sommes dans une position un peu délicate
parce que nous ne pouvons pas faire de
la publicité pour le jus de pommes
cerises noires le whisky de toute façon
je n'ai pas soi nguyen battant nice à
vannes ont justement monsieur monsieur
che rina ketty qui confond tout genre
d'alliance et c'est par vous qui dansait
le martyre de saint sébastien
enfin l'on pense non annoncé ma mort
puisque c'est bien ce que ça vient de
chez de charmilles à germinal
mais c'est cher monsieur thiam était
venu justement pour nous poser quelques
petites questions sur les feuilletons en
cour à bois naturellement mais nous
sommes là pour se reposer joseph aussi
des questions naturellement nous l'avons
rien à vous cacher le cd celui ci une
maison de verre maison de verre pas tout
à fait terminée comme vous pouvez le
constater ma fait de verre quand même
merci les feuilletons je sais passionne
le public est ce que vous recevez
beaucoup de courriers et coups sûrs
seulement en moyenne compter huit mille
à deux mille cinq cents à lettres ont
été un jour par jour c'est ce qu'il faut
compter parle pas des lettres de
compliments naturel moi oui parce que
nous n'en sommes pas mal
j'aurais 8
8 10 lettres par semaine non non non et
moi c'est plus que ça quand même compter
avec celle de ma femme et les vôtres ah
je pas conter ce lot faroter 18 à 20
valait une salle de matinée sous les
huit jours je m'arrête tous les bijoux
et vous répondez à tous courir
réponse non non on n'en parle pas
monsieur les gars tu m'envoies sa photo
est formé et où il on ne peut pas
répondre
d'ailleurs ouvrir dans le placard on va
vous montrer une montagne de lettres
appuis ça prouve l'intérêt de votre
mission
dites-moi est-ce qu'on pourrait en
profiter pour lire lui nous deux c'est
l'être c'est tout c'est toujours la même
chose
les feuilletons sans intérêt ça dure des
semaines et ce qu'on aime bien on les
voit jamais oui si au début de la soirée
à plusieurs reprises nous avons eu un
feuilleton est patent on voyait un grand
monsieur sympathique assis dans un bon
fauteuil devant une table et qui disait
des choses très intéressantes
parfois il enlever ses lunettes et lever
les bras au ciel je ne me souviens plus
de titres des épisodes mais je sais que
l'indicatif à la fin c'était la
marseillaise eh bien pourquoi on ne voit
pas tous les jours ce feuilleton là il
est éducatif est convenable et ça au
moins on peut le montrer aux enfants
tout cela prouve à quel point vous êtes
suivi avec intérêt avec passion même par
les téléspectateurs
mais dites moi pour faire face à tout ce
travail il vous faut des équipes
impressionnant nous engageons de jeunes
chanteurs auteurs patron tu proviens de
citer quelques noms
bah oui vous avez bien sûr que tu
rêverais vous allez graulhet qc les
relais
martial de la lutte que nous voulons
relier les molières ont des moyens ni
molière molière panpan par molière par
molière molière mollir un jeune homme un
jeune garçon qui sort du lycée qui a
toujours 18 et 19 ans aux rédactions ses
meilleures de sa causerie les trois qui
vont nous faire de très bons on fait ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre nos soucis
nous voulons des oeuvres propre c'est
certain un peu instructif
alors quand même pas à pas trop cher oui
insisté bien là dessus quand vous en
parler on ne peut pas se permettre de
faire cher c'est pas possible
il fait des défendre mais ça va très
vite ainsi voyez par exemple d'un janyk
et mais le facteur génétique et bien au
départ de la balade jaguar l'idée du
vélomoteur et de moi savions même pensé
à un moment on dit tous nous avions même
pensé à faire rouler un patin à
roulettes ou alors il fallait acheter
des patins nous avons préféré j'ai
préféré prêter mon vélo moteur personnel
ils marchent bien d'ailleurs
mais il a fallu payer de l'essence tout
de même à bâle il ya une petite
casquette une très bonne au moment du
fameux générique vous savez la pompe
tonne de graines tard il pas la saga
tintin nous avons tourné le plan sur une
déclivité eau libre
comprenez qu'on ferait du fort bien
passé sur le but vainqueur à dessein
c'est pas une bonne idée ça je comprends
qu'on pense et c'est très habile mais
dites-moi est-ce que ces difficultés
financières ne risque pas de sclérose et
votre imagination vous avez tout de même
des projets intéressants des projets
très intéressants en particulier nous
comptons mettre en chantier très
prochainement un feuilleton
qui serait une grande fresque historique
la salle le public adore ça quelle
époque elle est choisie moi je pensais
faire une chose sur la guerre de cent
ans carrément oh oui vous vous n'y
pensez pas la guerre de cent ans envoyé
des grands ou savez vous vous rendez
compte quand même six épisodes
ces quatre années en un quart d'heure
non c'est pas possible ou alors la
guerre la guerre de trente ans quand je
suis et vous lassez pas une mauvaise
qu'avant tout ce que vous voulez avec
les guerres du trotteur de malawi je
comprends bien il ne faut pas de
figuration considérable de grands décors
mais quel est le poids limite est ce que
par exemple vous pourriez faire un
feuilleton avec la pièce de pirandello
six personnages en quête d'auteur non
encore trop non à l'arrêt à l'alliance
qu'on pourrait faire sont les captent
sergent de la rochelle là non plus pas
de cinq provinces le tournage chaoui à
il ya les extérieurs ben oui c'est bien
mais je sais bien mais c'est pas facile
non plus il ya les trois mousquetaires
or on sait bien qu'ils sont quatre ah
bah je pense jamais à l'autre bien sur
wii waouh les deux orphelines
bah pareil elles retrouvent leur famille
à la fin c'est pas possible ça fait du
monde trop frais
moi je pense à un truc très bon jeu
serait carrément le les rêveries d'un
promeneur solitaire c'est qui
les rêveries d'un séjour à rousseau
patte d'oie le moteur trop important
dans un pays il est mort ya deux siècles
ah bon et peut-être des directives il
mettait ses enfants à l'assistance
publique à moi très bien décrète pas
très bien pourquoi c'est une oeuvre qui
vous intéresse je n'ai pas envie enfin
un projet satisfaisant les oeuvres
classiques qui ne coûtent pas cher
monsieur voilà voilà ce que nous
cherchons temps et que nous trouvons si
rarement la culture a lié à l'économie
comprenez vous et bien je vous remercie
monsieur des indications si important à
du tabou existentialiste de 1952 au
théâtre de dix heures en 1962 le chemin
parcouru par quoi réussir ou le même que
le vôtre celui de montmartre les a
conduits à une réussite exceptionnelle
et chaque soir monsieur chnops ans
remporte un véritable petit triangle
nous recevons chaque soir ici à notre
tribune une personnalité étrangère qui
vient nous exposer ses vues sur le
délicat problème de la liberté
individuelle
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand honneur de
céder la parole à monsieur alexandre
ch'nord ce cher monsieur chnops si vous
voulez bien si vous voulez bien d'entrée
je suis heureux de vous accueillir ici
je suis d'autant plus qualifiés pour
prendre la parole dans votre tribune que
j'ai quitté mon pays et que je viens
demander asile à la france
eh bien écoutez cher monsieur voyez-vous
sans avoir consulté qui que ce soit je
puis vous dire moi d'ores et déjà que
cet asile
nous vous l'accordons et le grand choeur
royal bien je n'en attendais pas moins
de fou voilà vous pouvez être rassurés
vous avez en quelque sorte choisi la
liberté alors j'ai selon la formule
usitée choisi la liberté oui j'ai
d'ailleurs l'impression qu'on peut hélas
de moins en moins vivre là-bas faut les
dire qu'on ne peut plus vivre du tout du
tout du tout du tout mais vous vous êtes
échappée de russie même où d'un pays
satellites de suisse
2 je me suis échappée de suisse c'est la
première fois que j'entends dire ça ce
ne sera pas la dernière j'ai montré la
voie d'autres suivront mais qu'est ce
qui a motivé votre départ de suisse
la tyrannie du régime helvétique pèse
surtout sur tout ah bon parce que le
régime helvétique est tyrannique
c'est à dire que toutes les libertés
sont réduites à néant tout simplement
nous vivons en vase clos
parlons un exemple quelconque vous
voulez respirer là bas n'est ce pas il
vient vous ne pouvez respirer que de
l'air suisse évidemment oui mais je
pensais à part ça qu'il existait une
grande liberté d'expression
mon cher ami liberté d'expression oui
pour les gens qui sont dans la ligne qui
se contentent de dormir de travail et de
boire de manger de se distraire à la
rigueur mais pour les autres les autres
ceux qui aspirent à autre chose alors
pour ces gens là c'est l'étouffement
alors les adultes bien entendu se
résigne mais il à jeunesse monsieur
notre pauvre jeunesse
c'est ça mais c'est le problème de la
jeunesse évidemment la jeunesse la
jeunesse est opprimé quoi un le mal
actuel de la jeunesse ne pénètre pas
chez nous la jeunesse est muselée mais
aucune fureur de vivre
aucun goût de la violence est cependant
monsieur cette jeunesse a besoin de
s'extérioriser
elle a besoin de frapper d'un sommet de
tuer comme partout ailleurs
bah évidemment si on ne tue pas à 20 ans
et pas cinquante qu'on le fera mais d'où
vient cette amortie autre idée d'où
vient cette mollesse à mon avis d'une
trop lourde hérédité de paix ça alors
écoutez franchement entre nous vous
rendez bien compte
on ne dépose pas les armes pendant des
siècles sans que la jeunesse en soufre
un jour ou l'autre
allons voyons une paix qui a fait un mal
fou à se payer et à tous ses enfants
mais sûrement et puis alors chez nous
vous comprenez pas d'exemple pas de
capitaine pas de jeanne d'arc
personne n'a jamais bouter les anglais
hors de suisse mais ils n'ont jamais
envahi la suisse non plus il faut dire
d'accord mais enfin on aurait pu les
provoquer à certains nous n'avons jamais
été regard avec la france
non est-ce que c'était bien nécessaire
merci quand même ne serait ce que pour
favoriser un rapprochement c'était
nécessaire
n'en croyez moi chez nous il y à une
invitation permanente à la paix oui
c'est la paix froide sont j'ai songé que
notre pays vient de subir trois grandes
paix mondiale monsieur avant sont des
choses des choses auxquelles on ne pense
pas toujours évidemment évidemment ce
sont des choses qui comptent des trois
grandes p3 grande paix en quoi en 100
ans exactement prenez l'exemple mon
grand père mon grand père a fait 71 14
18 39 et 45 63 3 p3p dans la vie d'un
homme ça compte ça compte quand même et
il est toujours de ce monde il a tenu le
coup il est toujours de ce mobile vient
de s'engager dans la légion
dans notre immeuble il y a aussi une
boutique d'antiquités une élégante
boutique tenue par deux et les grands
antiquaires son enseigne porte ou deux
hortense échoué depuis le temps que je
dis faut penser aux télés petite valise
rose qui sont habiles comme un club
grandit les deux petites palin euros
comment font elles sont vendues alors si
on continue à les avoir à vitré des
clients très content et le fait pas on
va être en proto gens ont tendance à
inquiéter
je voulais pas garder frais alors les
deux puis c'est pas les numéros rabat et
là bas tu n'as tu n'avais qu'à me dire
où tu vas quand tu as une option dessus
c'est la mesure qui les a pris en
juillet où la robe qu'elle était
finalement elle a pris à l'abri des deux
parce qu'elle voulait voir si ça
continue comme ça avait envie sur le
pont car il a continué lors plus rien
avoir du tout mais si c'est bien ça
d'ailleurs c'est pas sais pas ce qui se
passe en ce moment il ya un rush sur
l'antiquité je pense qu il va c'est
lorsqu'il ya six mois je suis enfin vie
ma collègue eric descout là qu'est ce
qu'on en fait on la jette ou quoi ils
coude ne me pose pas cette question je
t'ai jeu télé mais je t'ai je t'ai déjà
répondu si on n'a rien en magasin ce
beau monde se séparer de mariage et
malgré la régularité où elle est très
jolie qu'elle a fait redorer on a même
refusé tout particularisme - lampadaires
non vertueux c'est tu sais c'est terminé
c'est ma phrase passée romont romont
tout un client se disputer du temps le
québec n'est pas à vous que je termine
cette boîte de cirage que madame les
honneurs m'a demandé de monter en a
rajouté sur les yeux
bonjour monsieur je sens que je ne vais
pas vous désirez quelque chose au chai
besoins des différentes choses je
m'installe alors c'est pousser pour ses
poupées fischer boel attendez attendez
alors alors à ce moment-là si s'épancher
vous poursuit face des baquets je vous
ferai l'équipe michael fallait les
décorations je crois qu'ils les choses
comme ça oui alors je voudrais avoir un
renseignement oui
dans ce but là oui je dois savoir en
quoi vous êtes mobile est présentement
en charlemagne en charge charlemagne
nommé fin charlemagne à cheval sur fins
charlemagne et directe ou alors ça c'est
un grand cheval frison deux époques qui
vont bien ensemble c'est toshiba qui
colle à bois qui met la vie que moi
monsieur vous avez alors la grande table
de pierre alors oui je le menhir à
vavoua les baigneurs avec sa wii avec
des boues qui se rabattent à nyon dont
le nom d'un seul benoît amélie munier
sait très bien d'où on vient on nous
donnait on vous la fait monter en a pas
d'air
nous verrons une merveille de souvient
la lure savez mots bien lorsque ces
solides et shalit à quelques courses ça
nous a fait un usage où il va falloir
béquilles et y voit une autre chance
beaux murs a son importance aussi quand
délégation générale vos murs sont peints
ou tapissés quand son petit main dans
tout en mosaïque vous savez à la turque
oui conseiller parce que avec les médias
la mosaïque on peut paraître une foule
de choses dans ce qu'on lit vitesse cuir
et manière les besoins ses limites et
c'est quand même un film daredevil il
sera temps je vois ça y'a ka paul louis
saez qui puisse aller avec ça serait
tant pis ça non plus risquer le coup
mais vraiment raween à restaurer la
maison montre ton montre dans le
monsieur le petit secrétaire du ce
week-end de rentrée en 3d si je suis
montrée sans y arriver je tiendrais
j'avais su je voudrais vous poser une
question vous ne pensez pas ce que ça
trop fragiles non à ça vous savez sont
quand même des meubles qu'ils ont de
sens en éveil convient courant ce sera
évidemment il faut pas laisser lui mais
dictée non impossible
est-ce que vous avez l'eau courante chez
vous ah oui j'ai le courant tout ça vous
voyez je me déplace même pas parce que
je sais la réponse et ne supporte pas
son immeuble d'une susceptibilité
monsieur pouvez pas vous rendre compte
c'est comme des gosses sans surprise
c'est quoi c'est comme des grands
garçons et moi c'est comme des gros buzz
or on a failli avoir happé pas terrible
d'ailleurs avec avec le fauteuil en
fauteuil un cauchemar fauteuil louis xiv
va y avoir des envies d'ailleurs
asseyez vous ça vous dirait actionneurs
c'est une pdm pas pu revoir tester leurs
actes au oui oui c'est bien quand même
temps coriatt j'ai pas trois mois et
demi à 3 francs il doit envoyer
mécaloire ap rapporte souci des soucis
pas bref à vos journaux vendus à des
clients de passage mais je vous dis des
gens pas intéressant
toujours du théâtre action des tubes
nous leur avons rendu un très beau
fauteuil mais 14
ils étaient authentiques signés oui tu
as signé louis xiv joué 14 s'est passé
depuis 14 ans fait c'est fait monsieur
frère du roi rama étaient super voulez
bien
bref le fauteuil ne sait pas plus sur
ces gens là n'est ce pas c'est à dire
qu'on lui a fait des réflexions de
direction méchant non ces gens là mairie
des pins de chênes dans ce fauteuil lui
faire aux îles n'ai pas de style
on a été refait sur la mission n'en ai
pas achetés on est comme on est content
que ça demande pas tant devant il faut
d'ores et bien je ne sais pas on ne sait
pas
nous sommes passés ça m'a pas toujours
l'équipe qui s'est mis à dépérir à
s'étioler
il a bien dû sa forme et c'est devenu un
tout petit banc c'est comment tu peux
commander composer le ce que tu as fait
on en demande si je veux pas tout
simplement alors prendre une table en
cinq tableaux d'ingres et d'autres
choses et d'autres choses bien c'est pas
mal non plus je vous rappelle enfin que
je pars d'or et voyez monsieur de toute
façon faut toujours faire redorer oui
surtout le symbole eh oui ça si on veut
que ça va jonathan soit peu de ça on a
intérêt à faire j'aurais bien sûr
et alors mais on pense qu'il serait
peut-être pas mal à ce moment là je
pense à des choses que j'ai peur si
monsieur adopté ce principe de la table
ça va un peu du passé même si ce qui
serait peut-être bien c'est une babiole
lazio n'a pas vu non reliées aux petites
choses séparent ou un petit détail us à
une petite tasse de style petit quart
des pokes avoir l'air ravi sur un mois
on est merveilleux et à leurs pieds
alors élevée elle est ancienne mais je
pense qu'elle ne riez pas la même pas
doré sans les motifs n'ont pas de régime
at il cependant avoir magasins pour
essayer de vous la procurer marquant la
fin d'un jeu et de préférence pas en
porcelaine n'ont plus tellement fragile
je trouve que ça serait plus difficile
avec mêmes moyens oui j'irai jusqu'au
bout si elle n'avait pas tout à fait la
même forme et bien j'aimerais autant
voyez oui oui oui vous est fixé sur une
forte assise oui alors oui alors
effectivement nous avons nous avons un
arpu de son dos lui envoie oui d'une
forme un petit peu différente 100 ans
mais avec quatre pierres ne me gêne pas
du tout seulement c'est plus une tasse
et un escabeau c'est le seul ennui mais
enfin barça
oui mais j'en ai déjà non monsieur si
vous en avez rien tant pis alors je me
suis en mesure non seulement vous
entendez ici on ne sait pas ce que
voulez vous je me plaît je me blesse si
oui quelle pièce d'abord un livre non
mais c'est que tes rêves la même manière
ces salaires c'est quoi ce à quoi le nom
était battu c'est pour un living pour un
salon c'est quoi annoncer pour mon
armoire mais oui j'ai une grande armoire
vide alors je voulais me plaire qu'est
ce que vous me conseillez pendant ce
temps les enfants au foyer mieux de
mettre décembre comme motif décoratif 5
avril avait son dvd simple moyen non pas
d'air très bien ne brille pas forcément
ma forme
vous ne craignez pas que ça fasse un peu
nu des cintres seul comme ça quand même
je suis à vos chances vous pouvez y
accrocher des chaumes et vous dévoile
alors moi j'ai une série d un père par
exemple au mieux la banque pour qu'elle
devienne vraiment enfin nous les
versions très mais alors c'est moi sur
la planche dessus alors quelques
concerts de monter un lampadaire cédric
oui ou alors moi je pense est carrément
année sa maison de bretagne en leur
manière non pas des rounds le monde à la
fois non seulement alors alors on
soutiendra goutte alors que jeudi face à
jean-pierre veux pas ça ne m'aurait pas
je vous donne mon avis je suis d'autant
plus désolé que j'avais un cadeau à
faire écouter monsieur monsieur si vous
n'êtes pas trop pressés ont tout essayé
de vous le procurer ce cas oui mais
c'est un cadeau pour une cérémonie
alors tu vois c'est presse pour un
mariage ou un baptême nous rendait
second une veuve
ah bon vous aviez quelques jours en vue
ne sont pas spécialement venue d'une
petite console pour une box du louvre
les abris très bien la console wii 14
oui ça peut être amusant mais c'est déjà
une dame d'un certain âge alors ça va
nous avons plus que la console wii très
ce qui est très bien aussi donc je vais
de vous à moi j'aurais préféré faire un
cadeau moins important mais écoutez
monsieur enfin par la fin des fins dans
quel genre on arrête cette page avait vu
quelque chose d'autre choc aurait bien
fait mon avis mais il ya tout juste que
cette épreuve était de mettet nous
sommes là pour vous avez à présent faire
si j'ai bien sûr j'ai vu des choses et
m'a jamais dit les choses sans savoir
quoi là on veut dire c'est une espèce de
l'espèce de cointe de machin qui voit un
service à café
nous tenons à non une seule pièce non
seulement un récipient 1 cette année
donc là à lembeye directoire donc le
large une chaise à porteurs et
enveloppes thermiques en piste non je
crois que ça s'appelle comme cela guidon
non monsieur n'avait qu'une que un chien
normal je tiens de mes chiens c'est pour
quoi faire et fret
or une fois encore assez voilà une poêle
je me suis alors dit je sais pas ce qui
me retient vous jetez rapport de cette
boutique une ronde
ok c'est que ça c'est rien ça mais ça
sert à quoi ça sert à rien n'a rien rien
promet des serrures or harris et mathieu
quasiment être vraiment que c'est
curieux c'est absolument inutile le
faire à sa soul et moi je vous le
garantie sur facture
comment ça s'appelle un sert à rien
d'ailleurs c'est le nombre et ne pas
confondre avec le sert à tous les spas
qui a la même forme et on peut servir à
l'envi pour mille choses que vous me
jurez que ça ne peut être d'aucune
utilité te plait monsieur c'est semble
égal points sont à l'ordre et par ses
freins sont sept poissons de l'institut
de contrôle de serre à rien et a été
essayé moi dit elle pointe on sait qu'on
peut vraiment rien en faire ça n'aurait
pas ça si j'étais sûr que ça ne servait
strictement à rien je crois que je me
laisserais côté monsieur je voulais bien
monsieur si vous pouvez en faire le
moindre usage
moi je vous le répète c'est alors je
veux c'est une folie mais tant pis je
lâche atone et comportant des débats et
connais je vais essayer je vais essayer
à mon tour de manquer de vous en
procurer un semblable vous n'allez pas
que vous n'avez pas le même
malheureusement celui-ci est vendu je
peux pas recouvré franchement vous
souhaitez ce point de farol chaque fois
je vous demande quelque chose dont je
n'ai pas pris un sens je sais par une
fois à quoi ça ressemble et intérêts
ainsi qu'à vous avez une boutique alors
revendre et moi quelque chose
ah non mais vous ne connaissez pas je me
suis juré de faire une acquisition je la
fasse je ne chercherai pas d'ici là
monsieur on ne refuse pas la bonne mais
qu'on en a un abandonnera ya d'abord il
y aura quelques secondes on n'a rien on
n'a rien avant des bombardiers alors
s'il ya çà ou là ça va il ya cet article
là il ya ça faisait mouche car sa loi
aux failles que tu ne vas pas vous
écoute moi dont je suis bon commerçant
moi quand j'ai quelque chose que je ne
force pas vous me donnez une idée de
quelle époque et ils seniors méritants
mais si tu peux attention ça va tomber
rihaoui a su frapper
tu veux me laisser l'expliqué avec le
client à peu le cas n'est pas s'en
servir à quelle époque - arts décoratifs
mais c'est pas une copie non ce que vous
allez dire ce qui n'est pas plus jeunes
qui le paralyse je ne vous permets pas
je suis authentique vraiment monsieur
tout ce que nous avons ici et anciens
vous l'apprendrez et puis regardez les
coins si vous vous y connaissez vous
regardez les coins pas une moisissure au
coin bien pâle et pierre fun en europe
et quoi encore ah oui les piquets l'abbé
oui mais c'est la variole ce ne sont pas
les verts c'est donc ça c'est très
gentil mais qu'est ce que je vais en
faire
cfoot manqué d'imagination pour un grand
jeune homme de votre avis
c'est pas moi qu'est ce qu'on peut en
faire une tanche heures parce que ça
c'est gentil de ta chair une torchère un
petit [ __ ] de venise parloir avec un
flambeau dans les bras dans un vestibule
jeunes et nous et on ne veut pas qu'on
paye en noir ils ont rien ça va brasser
suffit comme ça et il se plonge avec
difficulté une chose ne me reconnais pas
le choix de sophie très bien revenant
faire un travail et wyatte et bien qu'à
changer ce qu avec les petits tiroirs
secrets rien on attend vous bien une
autre utilisation possible encore une
chose qui me vient à l'esprit est coupée
en deux peut-être le haut en porte
manteau pour accrocher des chapeaux le
banc porte-parapluie une fois qu'il sera
vidé qu'est ce que vous dites que ça
manque de chasse et a des maux femmes et
d'enfants tués dont tu as le bon vieux
notaire bien entendu monsieur si vous me
prenez je voudrais ville devient dans le
cas je me dégage la nuque et je crois le
pont s'annonce assez de faire pousser
quand même le client est roi il commande
on s'incline
nous n'avons pas le droit de celles
avancées trop dur tout ce qu'on a tout
ce qu'on a envie bon alors d'accord tu
me vends bien qu'aucune van sant avec un
bel art à jour et on en bas des banques
ont qu un coude